democrats ready to do all that it takes
to stop
republicans from filling the bacon
supreme court seat some in the party
threatening to pack the high court
even abolish the senate's filibuster
rule if the president's nominee gets
approved
senator chuck schumer and congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
urging democrats to use every option
available
we must also commit to using every
procedural
tool available to us to ensure
that we buy ourselves the time necessary
and to mitch mcconnell we need to tell
him
that he is playing with fire once we win
the majority
god willing everything is on the table
and speaker nancy pelosi she's not
ruling out impeaching
president trump for a second time take a
look
we have a responsibility we take an oath
to protect and defend the constitution
of the united states we have a
responsibility
to meet the needs of the american people
that is when we weigh the equities
of protecting our democracy requires us
to use every arrow in our quiver
so dana the question is how many arrows
are in that quiver because even if you
impeached president trump again or
impeached
attorney general barr the timing is
still up to mitch mcconnell
i believe yeah so if you remember when
president obama had that
obamacare meeting with uh john mccain
and he got irritated and he said look
john we won
and in some ways like yeah like
elections do have consequences as i
mentioned republicans often will vote
based on this issue of judicial
nominations i think democrats are kind
of
catching on to the idea that they need
to focus on it too but i don't
understand what possible other tool
the congresswoman is suggesting be used
procedural rules
yeah you could argue that they were
important but republicans weren't the
first to change them
if you remember in was it 2013 it was
harry reid
who decided to end the filibuster for
appellate nominees to get three of
obama's nominees
past the process and into the court okay
so mitch mcconnell says yeah i wouldn't
do that if i were you
that's a bad idea that's a bad precedent
they did it anyway
so then president trump comes along he
has two possibilities to put on the
court
gorsuch and kavanaugh and what does
mcconnell do
changes the rule so like they always
want to change i'm not for changing the
rules per se
i like tradition i like the constitution
i like the way our founding fathers set
it all up
but the idea that the threat is
you don't do a nominee or we will pack
the court
i think it just gives more fuel to the
republicans
all right so greg you think about a 63
conservative majority
a trump court really they get rid of
pre-existing conditions
get rid of obamacare gender equality
labor bargaining goes out the door
marriage absolutely we're going to get
rid of gender equality
that's the first on my list wow i want
every i want men and women to be unequal
i'm an evil right winger yeah you forget
about the vmi case which was justice
ginsburg right
that says that bmi had to admit women
for the first time i think it was 157
years
you think about little bretter and i'm
against progress juan you go okay so i'm
saying
what that all at risk was your argument
is no one's going to reverse that okay
and by the way nothing that pelosi is
saying or
or chuck schumer saying means anything
they blew their threat wad for four
years they've been painting their
adversaries not as political adversaries
but as moral enemies
you know we're bigots we're racists
we're monsters so it's like okay you
know what
hm let's listen to them for once and do
what they say and then maybe they'll be
nice to us
that's not how it works they're still
gonna try to eat us alive
because they're political animals and
they're making a huge mistake
i understand hyper partisanship
completely i get it it's a team sport
but they're aligning themselves with an
antarctic
nihilistic ideology that's on the
streets they think that the radical left
is their
useful idiot no it's the people on the
streets destroying
destroying and burning things that are
using the democrats as their useful
idiot because the
democrats don't want to upset them so
together they're coming after
us and until the adults in the
democratic party stand up to this stuff
it's just going to snowball into
something way way worse they're just
going to use this nomination
as another conduit for violent strife so
jesse
you know we're all back together i need
you to comfort me because i got to tell
you i'm very
six feet juan i know but i mean i don't
know what i can do you know what friends
have to say you know what
even across political lines you have to
understand i'm very upset about this
i mean to me the mcconnell rule
basically is this
democrats don't appoint supreme court
justices only republicans appoint
supreme court well i thought i explained
this
in the first block is it when the party
controls both the senate and
the white house forget your justice
nobody said that before that's a couple
well actually biden said it yeah
it's raw power and it breaks down the
institutions you were talking about
no because you know what you guys are
the ones threatening to abolish the
electoral college pack the court
and add puerto rico in d.c so i don't
want to hear about institutions plus
you have no credibility on this issue
after you impeach the
president during an election year after
you sabotage the transition
spied on his campaign slimed kavanaugh
and then threatened to riot if you don't
get your way
you've surrounded mcconnell's house he's
had to call the police
because they're intimidating his family
i think this shows the voters this
that this is how crazy the left will go
when they're out of power
imagine what they'll do with power you
can't trust them my advice to democrats
want
win elections if you win the senate if
you win the white house
you can appoint and confirm as many
justices as you want
when there's a vacancy right now you're
panicked because your nominee is shot
he slept all through saturday and then
he waltzes to philly
and speaks about this during an eagles
game no one paid attention
he's out of breath leaves without taking
questions
and says we're in a constitutional
crisis there's no crisis with the
constitution
there's a crisis with the democratic
party because joe says he wants to
return to normalcy
but what's normal about shredding every
institution
because you're mad that's not normal
that's crazy
and now he's in a tight spot with his
base i well this is a good point because
i think the one shredding the
constitution is someone else but i
wanted to ask dagan about just what
jesse said the base
because i think this is firing up
democrats
terrifically as we head toward the
election day
i will repeat something that dana said
in the first block because i talked to a
big old democrat
earlier in the day and he said anybody
who is voting for joe biden as a
democrat
because of the court is already his vote
it's the moderate
republicans who don't like president
trump but the court
does matter to them and the republicans
need to treat
this you know get rid of the filibuster
pack the court it's two
four even six new justices add some you
know get rid of the electoral college
and add some states
to the the 50. you have to treat
those threats as hard core promises for
the progressive limits you have to treat
it as if it's going to happen
regardless of whether republicans cave
on filling this vacancy or not
and i'll just go back you went through
this litany of things that you're
concerned about
hey guess what legislative branch you
can address
all of those things through the congress
and how about private industry
and start talking about gun rights as
gun ownership has
skyrocketed in this country right now
because of all the violence in our
streets
because the court the court did not take
up that gun rights case it rendered
it moot this case of dealing with new
york and new york
city and you start talking about gun
rights and you'll get a lot more people
on board regardless of who's in that
seat
gun control's dead